[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I wasn't really pointing at any of you
that's a trick politicians do yeah
ah whether we're gonna show and what if
so we have for you this evening probably
our best show ever never got the goods a
fantastic should I love tonight's show
given I showed her a real talk of a show
for you where ever my program thank the
best show we have to such a good show
tonight show a solid B I like it who
says that no one ever says that uptight
program well this one should be adequate
watch tonight
Conan's adequate we're gonna do much
better than that we got one of the best
show ever I say absolutely yeah
all right screw that no one bought it
didn't work let's talk about this
[Applause]
please welcome Zach Galifianakis
[Applause]
it was incredibly impressive what a fall
yeah I got confused how the inner Turner
we are very honored to have you here
again yeah peppermint pattie sister
watching you defiled my beloved TBS
night after night with its amateur turd
rain it's time once again for families
lays down in peace until in my latest
Conan's videoblog NBA mascots that
should never dunk contact would you want
to make a facebook picture with me get
it's time to play basic table name that
to Conan O'Brien or directors sports
Brad flaming C lose round live from 30
feet above me
he's a small man you know physically and
spiritually
[Music]
you know what I'm gonna go on record
right now and say I will do this show
Gilligan
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
weeknights at 11 only on TBS very funny